It is not a coincidence that the Western individual is intuitive
A person has been unfairly hanged on a cross and tortured
"It's like ..." Yes
"Right"
"!exactly"
So what do you do about it?
Okay
I thought about it for a long time too
It's like ... well you do not pile up with crowds
Because all it does is to allow you to be as horribly as you can imagine and suffer through nothing
This is a bad idea
So what about not doing it
"Well, there's a deep idea in the West too, it's like" pick up your damned suffering and bear it
Try to be a good person in order not to make it worse
this is the truth
I read a lot about the terrible things people did to each other
You can not even imagine it
Very awesome
So you do not want to be someone like that
Now do you have a reason to be? Yeah
You have so many reasons, my God there are so many reasons to be very upset because of you
Everyone you know will die
You know, you too
There will always be an amount of pain and much of it will be unfair
"It's like" Yeah, no wonder you're upset "It's like" act out and see what happens
You make everything you complain about
The worst is without limits
There is this idea that hell hole is not her decision
Because no matter how bad it is, there is a stupid son of a bitch like you can find a way to make it much worse
"So you think" What do you do about it?
Well accept it, this is what life is, it is suffering
This is what the religious have always said: life is suffering
Yes really
So, who wants to admit it? Well, just think about the subject then what to do with that suffering
Try reducing them
Start with yourself
How useful are you?
You own yourself with Christ, so when your father dies, you will not be far away in the corner
While you can help plan the funeral and you can stand firm so people can count on you
Is it better than being a victim of a sample? Of course you are a victim
Rabah, for sure
..Take yourself, and perhaps Tamtlk yourself then know how to do it
You know what your speech is, if you have to admit it
You know there are a few things you can improve a bit
You may even be able to arrange your current situation
So maybe make yourself shine a little and then your eyes will open slightly
And then you can make yourself shine more and then perhaps you can gather your family again
Instead of being the embryos of hatred, hatred, and nepotism that are governed by Christmas
So when you fix yourself a bit, be humble, because .. Learn, my God, that you are a "reformer and a reformer" if there is such a thing
Then you have to find a way to solve ... well
Can you find a way to reconcile with your foolish brother?
How the hell will you deal with it?
And then perhaps you reach something and start your family to play its role in some way
"Well ... that somehow removed some of the suffering," he said, although he played down the chances of vengeful revenge
This kind of pain is so annoying that after a few gatherings of your family
And be a little consistent, at least a little because you did something difficult
Which is actually difficult, you are more wiser
So maybe you can try and try away from the family and try to change some small things without destroying them
Our society is complex, and we teach our students that they can simply reform it
"It's like" I go and fix a military helicopter and see where it will go
"It's like .. you'll act like a chimpanzee with a big screwdriver." Look, it's better
The answer is not that it is not the best, complicated stuff and fixing things is very difficult
You have to act as a golden tool to fix things
And you are not
So this is the other message from the West
They are like: How do you overcome the suffering of life?
I'm not saying it's just a West letter
How can the suffering of life be overcome? Be a better person
So do it well, that's hard
Requires responsibility. I think if you tell someone you want a meaningful life?
Everything you do makes a difference
This is the definition of meaningful life everything you do makes a difference
You must carry it with you
Or do you want to completely forget about the theme of meaning
Then you do not have any responsibility, because who may matter? You can go around life as you want
Satisfactory to reckless desires, it may be of benefit
And be stuck in the mean but without having any responsibilities which one you want?
"Well, ask yourself" Whom are you seeking?
And you will quickly find that it is not the majority of your soul that is seeking all the subject matter because .. see what you should do to do so
You have to take the fact that life is suffering you have to face yourself in this way
Well that's tough, it's amazing that people can even do it
I am amazed every day when I'm out and I do not find riots and fire in everything
It is possible .. God .. Talk to people and be like
I know someone who has been involved in a motorcycle accident
The accident had actually wrecked him, and his work was on electrical wires
He worked with someone with paralysis
They had complementary to the palaces, as two of them can do one person's work so they are there to repair electricity poles in the cold cold
Despite the fact that one of them was three quarters broken by the bike accident and the other has paralysis paralysis
This is how our civilization goes, there are all these people who are destroyed
They have problems you can not believe
They go to work, do things they do not like and even see, the lights are on
God, it is a miracle
It's a miracle, we are very naive, college students, postmodern types, very reluctant
They do not know that they are surrounded by a miracle to sample it as a miracle how all these things work
You, all the crazy chimpanzees who do not know each other, can sit here together in the same room, soaring for two hours without tearing each other apart.
Because that's what chimpanzees do
And therefore
Anyway, so
what happened? Well, I've done some videos
I got to the heart of some things, at least to the extent that I can say so I told you what is the core
I had this idea about what to do about it and that is not my idea .. not my idea
It is a very old old fashioned idea very very much older than Christianity
It is ancient, it is the oldest story of mankind
Rank and own yourself
Overcome your suffering, see if you can be somehow a hero
Make suffering in the world less
Well, this is way forward as far as I can tell if there is any way forward
Nothing is under attack by the postmodernists
So be aware that they know exactly what they are doing and know exactly why they are doing it